Dennis waitley is the man that
astronauts to heads of States call to
learn at the highest level he's the
author of 16 books and has sold more
than 10 million audio programs that have
led to $100 million in sales in this
exclusive interview with Chris Weidner
you'll hear Dennis's best advice on how
to overcome setbacks how selfworth
influences your net worth and why you
need to model success and we got Chris's
permission to put it up on our YouTube
channel enjoy Dennis waitley welcome
thank you it's great to be with you yeah
it's good to have you here now um I like
to help people get to know the person
behind the personality because
particularly especially when we're when
we're sitting down with someone like
yourself who is so well known throughout
the world and anybody who has even
remotely studied any sort of personal
development self-mastery has heard the
name Dennis waitley and most likely
according to the statistics read one of
your books or listened to one of your
audio programs and so uh this is just an
informal chance for us to get to know
you and the the thoughts that you have
brought about and brought to fruit
truition over the years and so I'm
excited to be with you you and I spent a
little bit of time together but uh I
like to hear some of the stories as well
so maybe you could tell us a little bit
about your early life well it's not too
uh exciting except that I was raised
during the World War II era and uh like
all speakers I came from a poor family
you know how we all say that we've
overcome adversity to become great and
uh I never went to bed hungry but we
didn't have any money my idea of money
my dad made $200 a month was as big as
paycheck and uh he said you could never
live in a house like that the rich
people live there and they're born that
way or crooked so my dad thought you had
to be either born with it or crooked to
get it and uh my mother made sandwiches
uh for school and they were two pieces
of Wonderbread mayonnaise and lettuce a
little pepper and salt and I looked in
it and I said what is this she said
that's a chicken sandwich without the
chicken I said how do you get the
chicken and she said you got to go mow
some Lawns and go to the store and bring
your mama home with chicken so we didn't
have money and my idea would have been
maybe $800 a month would have been a a
king's Ransom but uh it was a good
childhood I listened to a lot of radio
which maybe got my radio voice you know
listen to Sky King who was Earl
Nightingale in those days and so I
developed an audio kind of ear for the
spoken word and that was one of the
things uh reading a lot and listening a
lot uh was an early childhood kind of
thing now you mentioned ingest but it is
true you know so many people say well I
was born very poor and had hardships uh
why do you suppose it is that so many
people start out in sort of a you know
tumultuous times or hard times but then
they go on to achieve such great things
I mean is there is there something about
that in our formative years that makes
us go on and and Achieve great things or
I really think so I think so many people
have so much going in they don't take
anything out or forward but if you you
don't have too much going in then you're
compensating for what you don't have and
you try harder and work harder so
sometimes it's better to overcome
adversity because then you really
appreciate success when you get it so
when you were growing up did you say I
want to become wealthy or I want to
become a a world famous speaker or I
think the speaking actually came out of
the other things that you did we're
going to talk about but did you have
these sort of I want to escape and have
more than what I had as a child sure my
mom and dad argued a lot about money my
D drank too much and smoked too much and
instead of being a chip off the old
block I wanted to be different uh than
my dad I wanted to be a a man of the
family and they argued so much I figured
that they must be arguing about
something that wasn't good so I wanted
to be different from my father but uh I
think I was inadequate and had ideas of
self-doubt and I think in order to get
any self-esteem I had to go out and
prove myself which means in athletics
and in school that was a way for me to
see that I was better than where we were
coming from it's interesting you find a
lot of people who didn't get that kind
of self-esteem spoken to them by parents
and so it's almost like we grow up
trying to to achieve it so that we can I
don't know prove it to ourselves or
prove it to our parents was there some
of that you wanted to to show your
parents how much you could become oh a
lot of that in fact uh when when I was
about 9 years old my dad would come into
my room and he'd been drinking and he he
would lean back against the light switch
and blow it out and I said how'd you do
that he said I got bad breath from
drinking he said but when the light's
out for you my son it's out all over the
world and he said I don't want you to
grow up like me you don't have to be
like me but remember when you sleep the
world is sleeping your dream when you
wake up the world stretches and awakens
with you and when you're not feeling
good the world isn't a good place the
only World you'll ever know is the one
you see through your eyes and I said wow
what a responsibility that I have to
make the world as I see it through my
eyes and I think that helped me because
he left home for good when I was nine
and I was left to be the man of the
family with my little brother who became
my little Shadow and my sister so I had
to overcome where we came from I think
at that age so you had a lot of
responsibility thrust on you that seems
be another aspect of overachievers is is
people uh they experience responsibility
in an early age so I'm they grow up too
fast is that part of it as well well I
think I had to you know take care of my
mom and she said you know I don't want
you to grow up like your dad and you
need to be a good man and so I would
ride my bicycle about 20 mi one way to
go to my grandmother's house because at
home I still felt inadequate but at
Grandma's house she made me feel like I
was special she said you're a good boy
and you mow a good lawn and I'll give
you a piece of lemon pie because you're
such a good boy and I was thriving on
any kind of positive input I could get
and she was the one that gave me the
positive input now you mentioned your
grandmother is this maternal or paternal
Grandma it's maternal okay maternal and
you mentioned as we were preparing for
our conversation you know I said who are
your role models and you mentioned your
grandmother tell us about that well
she's the primary role model in my life
and she and I planted a victory garden
during World War II we put these little
seeds in the ground and she said
whatever you put in comes up and I said
wow how do you know how do you know it's
going to look like that and she said
because that's the way you plant it she
said the weeds will come in Uninvited
and unannounced you don't have to even
water the weeds but you plant the seeds
of greatness and you grow vegetables or
fruit or good people so remember model
yourself after people with proven track
records of success and you'll plant the
seeds of greatness in yourself and she
kept filling me with that kind of input
and so the seeds of greatness was like
gardening for me and I I really believe
that you cultivated and harvested what
you plant and where was this when you
were growing up what uh area of the
country were you San Diego California
still San Diego yeah I was in San Diego
and and and uh I still live there and my
children grandchildren live there but I
have fond memories of of my grandmother
believing in me when that's all I had to
hang on to yeah um as you travel around
one of the things I'm sure you talk
about is um avoiding naysayers and the
people who speak negative things but
then also the the selft talk that we
tell ourselves and believe about
ourselves um how can people maybe they
don't have a grandmother or an aunt or
an uncle maybe they're not getting it
from their parents or brothers or
sisters or or even their spouse how can
we find somebody who can be a positive
influence in our lives somebody who can
encourage us build us up like your
grandmother was for you uh you weren't
getting it at home and so your
grandmother became that for you and and
gave you the lift that you needed
mentally and well there's several things
you can do obviously it's good to be
involved in organized extracurricular
activities you find it in sports on a
team you find it in music with a band
you find it by joining a camera club or
a you know a reading club some kind of
Club where people are doing positive
things you know you belong even if it's
wrong with a gang but belong to some
kind of organized activity where people
have the same goal rather than the same
problem that's one thing but the most
important thing I think is to read
biographies of people who have overcome
enormous obstacles to become successful
you read about colon pollen Oprah
Winfrey you read about Jack custo and
you read about these average people
common people who become uncommonly
successful and you say wow they're not
so special at least they weren't when
they were kids so maybe there's a chance
for me if they did out of adversity what
they did maybe I could too and you learn
that they overcome enormous problems to
become successful because that's what
drove them what do you do if you have
somebody in your life who is a close
family member maybe a spouse or or even
parents who still living even if we're
we're older um who are not particularly
positive about the dreams that we want
to achieve the work that we want to
pursue uh those types of things how how
do you overcome that I mean you don't
want to sever the
relationship uh and and yet we want to
cultivate this atmosphere in our lives
that is is positive and uplifting is
there any tips you can give people who
might find themselves in that situation
well I've been in that situation because
my mother's always been very negative uh
she's 96 as as we speak and believes
that I should get a real job
uh she gives me classified ads so you
know wanted a good man for $1,500 a
month with car still to this day yeah
and she said the other day uh do you
think anyone in our family will ever
become successful and I said well you
know maybe the grandchildren mom but
what I've learned to do with her is I
realized that she did the best she could
with what she had to work with and that
I wasn't going to change her belief so I
pull the Venetian blinds on the negative
thing she said and everything she said
negative I tried to reverse it it's a
hot day I said good Sun
she said it's raining I said good for
the flowers so I would always come back
with a positive even though she came in
with the negative and that way I could
reverse the thought and the other thing
I did is develop selective listening
when people would complain you know pity
parties group griping Grudge collecting
I would really try to selectively hear
what the solution would be to the
problem they were talking about so I
think it's very important to have a
mastermind group and to hang around with
optimists if you're around a negative
atmosphere you have to have a good
friend who's an optimist or you have to
belong to some kind of group that's
talking about things that's why I have
lunch about once a week with people who
might have similar goals but different
backgrounds and they challenge me to do
better otherwise you might stay in some
rut that you were in simply because the
people around you were maybe poisoning
the water a little bit and of course the
media and the commercial media and news
media a little bit that's one great
thing about this kind of program you
know bad news cells the fire that Burns
another warms the general population and
the fact they're glad they weren't the
victim of the day so people pass on bad
news it makes them insulated and
isolated from the problem and they're
glad that they weren't out there in the
same way and it makes them feel better
being mediocre than go challenging
themselves because things are liable to
turn out bad yeah yeah TV nowadays it
seems like what's the old saying if it
bleeds it leads you know and and that is
really one of the goals here is to is to
open people's minds to the ideas and the
people are promoting these kinds of
ideas to help them understand that that
they can become better that they can
succeed that they can achieve the things
that they want to achieve now I want to
go back just a moment to Parenting
because we're going to talk at the end
of the show about some really exciting
stuff that you're doing but uh I was
reminded of the story I believe it was
Ted Turner when he won time man of the
year and he held up the magazine when he
won it he said is this enough dad you
know and why is it that the people who
are closest to us can sometimes be the
the hardest on us whether it's a parent
or a spouse what what takes place there
why why when we say that we love
somebody can we be so tough on them I
guess we we love them so much that we're
so critical of them we keep digging up
the the the seeds that are planted to
see how they're doing and what's bad
about that is you you feel inadequate
because they're criticizing you they're
being a judge rather than a a role model
they're being a Critic instead of a an
encourager and parents don't really
realize how important it would be to
just listen to children and show
interest in what they're doing instead
of trying to make the children
vicariously live their lives over again
so that's really what many parents want
they want their children to prove that
they're that the parents are good and so
that's a real problem when I was about
12 I had a recurring dream so you asked
me about positive thinking and how I got
into this I had a dream over and over
again it wasn't a nightmare it was a
good dream and I was in a tuxedo and and
I was older and I was in Carnegie Hall
and I was standing there in front of the
audience and they Rose to their feet and
gave me a standing ovation and in the
front row was mom and dad and my family
my grandma and I remember saying in the
dream is it okay now am I okay is is
that acceptable behavior I mean am I am
I a good boy now because grandma is the
only one that said it not Mom or Dad or
not they so I was proving myself in
those dreams as somebody that could do
something special and about
253 years later I found myself in a
tuxedo in Carnegie Hall and I did get a
standing ovation but my parents weren't
there but it still was the same effect
on me I still said to myself I'm okay
now it's too bad that we need external
approval though you know that we need an
audience to tell us that we're okay
would be better if we were internal if
we played a beautiful piece on the piano
and we knew it was good because we did
it for the sake of Excellence but if you
have to have an audience then it means
maybe you're still trying to prove
yourself yeah I think there's a balance
because I think we we were created with
a need for other people otherwise if we
were completely independent you know I
wouldn't need you you wouldn't need me
we all live our separate lives but
really where it it gets out of whack is
when it becomes you know an overwhelming
need or um an unhealthy need how do you
how do you balance that between you know
you you want your mother's approval you
want your father's approval but you
can't live off of your mother and
father's approval does that make sense I
mean how do you find and what's so good
about what you just said is that you
want to play for a gallery of one which
is your own idea of being created for
excellence but at the same time you want
to help other people and you really want
to be a good friend to other people and
one of the ideas in life is to create
other winners
and that's one way where you can instead
of just gaining approval you can
actually help other people achieve their
dreams and if you get out of yourself
and into them you really don't worry so
much about yourself and you don't become
selfish you can have good self-esteem
but still give yourself away and you've
given up nothing by sharing the best in
you you haven't given up anything but
you couldn't keep it anyway so unless
you give it away knowledge and money are
the same thing they don't do any good
when you have them right they only do
you good when you employ them so I think
it's a great idea to say sure I'm as
good as the best but no better than the
rest and one of the things I need to do
is pass my winds along and that makes me
feel better for Being Human so it's the
balance between on one hand you don't
want to be dependent on somebody else on
the other hand you don't want to be
completely independent or autonomous you
want that interdependence sure and and
then you're helping each other so it's
it's a shared Victory it's it's a double
win if you win I win if I help you win
then I win too yeah healthy interaction
so who were some of your other Role
Models over the years you've met I mean
everybody you know who have been some of
the people that you've looked up to
who've taught you who you've learned
from who've really made a a a nice
investment in your life well I think you
know Billy Graham has been one really uh
I remember him looking at me and he said
how many lives have you changed Dennis
and I
said I said one Dr Graham uh I've
allowed mine to be changed but I I don't
change people's lives and he said me
neither he said I give them what I
believe in they come down from the
Outfield to the infield give them some
literature and a prayer and they usually
go back to being themselves unless at
that moment they've intersected a
commitment that they make to change and
I said wow that's kind of the way I feel
but you've done it with a lot more
people Dr Graham so he's been one that
has been authentic an authentic uh
preacher he walks the talk another one
has been Dr Jonas s and he was my mentor
and boss for many years he's the one
that discovered the first polio vaccine
and he said you know you're a crazy guy
you know nothing about science but a lot
about people he said why won't people
invest in science and I said because it
isn't any fun people will do what they
want before they do what they need and
therefore they'll spend their money on
tension relieving instead of goal
achieving he says so what we have to do
is make investing in the future fun I
said exciting
passionate and not don't pull too much
on their negative emotional heartstrings
but give them an excitement and they
will invest in it and he said that's a
good lesson he said so what about a
hidden agenda what is that I said that's
what people are really coming for and
the thing we ask questions for Dr Su is
to find out what they really want we do
a want analysis and we find out what
they're coming for and that's a hidden
agenda so he was a great role model he
said you know you ought to go back to
school I'll help you get back I'll help
you get into psychology if you're going
to be selling a dream you better be
underpinned with good psychology so he's
the one that encouraged me to get a
doctorate in human behavior and
introduced me to a lot of really
important people like Abraham maslo and
uh Victor Frankle and William Glasser
and some of the real icons in the Carl
Rogers uh and that gave me the incentive
to want to be more professional about
what I did I want to go back uh as we
transition out of the role models and
all that to uh Annapolis I mean that's
that's a pretty amazing my son wants to
go to Naval Academy that's one of his
big dreams and very few people get to
have that kind of experience how did you
end up at Annapolis well of course it's
the only way you can get a free
education when you don't have any money
and when the Korean war is on instead of
carrying a rifle you want to go hide in
a service Academy but my dad said that
if I stayed in the Navy kept my nose
clean and didn't Rock the Boat I could
retire with $800 to $1,000 a month he
said that really early in life so before
he left home he really planted the seed
that maybe a free education a service
Academy so I was obsessed with it told
everyone that that's where I was going
to go and then realized you needed an
appointment Yeah by a congressman so I
tried to get you know Senator Nixon to
give me an appointment and then I didn't
get that so I had to join the naval
Reserve they activated my unit put me on
a submarine and were sending me to Korea
and I said this is not going to work so
I studied really hard to pass the fleet
examination got into the Naval Academy
and sure enough my mentor and big
brother there was H Ross perau oh really
yeah Ross perau was the Brigade
Commander there and he had that same
fiery intensity as he had when he used
to run for president a couple of times
but he was a really good role model an
example for me at the Academy and I I
think that I wasn't cut out to be a
career service officer
but on the other hand it taught me some
discipline it taught me some goal
setting it taught me that takes a lot
more effort than you think and it was
really good for me that's that's why I
became a pilot because it was exciting
and and passionate yeah what kind of
planes did you fly I flew uh first the
old ad and then the a4d so I became a
low-level attack carrier based pilot
being catapulted off in the middle of
the night can you imagine a poet being a
pilot yeah you know every Landing was a
control craft on the carrier as long as
I caught a wire it was great yeah it's
amazing so how did you get then you got
this period of time we talked about your
early life then we talk about going to
Annapolis and the things that you
learned there how do you go from being a
fighter pilot to being a best-selling
author and speaker what what took place
over that what was the transition give
us a lay of the land there well I was
more interested in people than I was in
in uh being a combat pilot I was always
trying to help the people Help the
enlisted men and and be a guy that was
speaking more and of course what do a
naval officer wants to be an admiral do
speaking so I even then I began to be
interested in personal development
rather than in just being a Defender but
I think resigning my commission getting
out of the Navy uh had some small
children I went to work for aex
corporation which had just invented the
videotape recorder and then I went to
Russia to this world fair there and
Nixon and kusf were in the and debating
and Cru Jeff had his shoe and he said
we'll bury your grandchildren nixson
said no you won't and we smuggled out
the videotape in our underwear back to
the United States and I think the idea
of video and marketing and management
got me more interested in public service
and in publicity but it wasn't until I
came down to the so Institute and met
Jonas suul and decided to raise money
for him and he said I hate to speak
so you're going to go out and speak for
me while I'm in the kitchen making the
formula and everyone would be angry
because here this guy coming and they
said you're no Jonah salul I said no but
but I'm going to tell you why science is
so important so I had to explain
complicated scientific things in
layman's terms and I think I developed
at that time an ability to go out and
speak over and over and over again it
was the fact that I did a little tape on
you know P because at the same time
during the 70s I became a a
rehabilitation coordinator for the
Vietnam prisoners of war and on top of
that I wrote my doctorate thesis on why
no American prisoner ever escape from a
minimum security Camp during the Korean
War I couldn't believe it if you're in a
minimum security Camp you don't try to
escape but there's no barb wire if
you're in a maximum security Camp
there's barbwire and dogs and machine
guns and you you escape why because
you're a leader when you're purpose full
you know where you're going when you're
purpose less you stay for the duration
so that became a an underlying thesis
for my whole if you will pitch in life
was P could be prisoner of war could be
Prince of Wales could be power of women
could be prisoner of wishes prisoner of
work but more likely it could be
psychology of winning depending on what
you did with it psychology of winning
when when people say Dennis weightly and
at least when I hear that I think of two
things psychology of winning seeds of
greatness and um so you you come out
with this audio program psychology of
winning and as we've talked you told me
something really interesting you said I
didn't do it so much for other people
you did it for yourself how did that how
did that all come about how did you end
up going from doing what you're doing
speaking on behalf of uh Dr sulk and
then all of a sudden creating the
bestselling audio program of all time
how does that how does that happen
because I was losing instead of winning
and because I was losing I I wasn't
doing well professionally I I uh sold
the so Foundation to another Foundation
I ended up in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania in
the middle of the winter not being
wanting to be there I was a California
boy I'm in the worst winter I don't have
a job anymore because this St Foundation
is being closed down my kids want a
mutiny
I'm a single father with four children
and my children don't want to be the Bad
News Bears anymore they want to go back
to California they want to be in
Pittsburgh my son wanted to play
football and they mutinied on me and
there I was in the middle of the winter
saying I'm not a winner I'm a
loser what would make a winner If I
Could Be A Winner what would I do and I
began to do more of my own research more
of the things I learned from Suk and
from the other behavioral scientists and
I wrote the program for me not based on
my success but based on what I wasn't
doing and that's why I think that some
people wait until they perform to feel
valuable What If instead you felt value
would lead to your performance and what
if you could learn at the worst time of
your life that that might be the moment
where you could bring the best out of
you cuz when things are going well you
Coast when things are not going well you
have two choices one follow in it or get
out of it so I wrote that program night
after night day after day people would
see me coming in this Medical Center in
Pittsburgh and say what are you doing I
said I'm writing a program for myself to
try to get out of here and they said
you're a California boy you want to go
home and I said I want to go home with
my family and so I wrote it for myself I
did a small tape of it Earl Nale
happened to hear the tape because World
Book childcraft had sent it to him
because I did a speech for them and he
called me and said you know you have a
nice voice you're not well known but you
have a nice voice good material I think
maybe you know maybe we might be able to
use you and that was he had the only
tape program out in the spoken voice
lead the field and The Strangest Secret
I still really believe in The Strangest
Secret I believe we become what we think
about most of the time I definitely
believe we become that to which we're
most exposed and I think the exposure
really leads to a reflex Behavior
because it's all habit and habits are
are really comfortable they they're easy
to get into they're hard to break
they're really replace and they go from
cobwebs in the cables so for me uh the
Tape album was done for me Earl
Nightingale discovered by some
intersection and I was lucky that they
used that album to build a mailing list
I mean I wasn't known so what do you use
the album for yeah send it out you know
send out the stuff why would they send
that stuff out on me because I didn't
demand a high royalty because I wasn't
well known and wasn't that confident of
myself to demand a royalty but had I
demanded a high royalty they would never
have done it so I got really lucky that
they used me as a front-end list Builder
how old were you at the time I believe
it I was almost 40 so I was in my late
30s so you know it shows you that you
can either have either have permanent
potential but you don't have to do it
when you're a teenager you can put it
all together by taking everything you've
learned and turning failure into
fertilizer or experience uh into
something that comes together later in
life and that's why I didn't really
start making it until I was in my late
30s and early 40s so I think that we all
reach a crossroad in Life or we can we
don't have to believe that we're a
failure because we haven't found out
where we're going even when we're in our
late 30s or 40s hey there it's Chris
Weidner and I hope that you're enjoying
this interview that I did with one of
the legends of personal development and
if you'd like even more information and
great resources from the legends of
personal development all you have to do
is click on the link below in the
description and I've got a plenty more
for you so with that let's get back to
the
interview you U mentioned a couple of
people at particular times have come
into your life and you weren't even
really looking for them were you I mean
you weren't looking for Earl Nightingale
all of a sudden he he kind of shows up
and the tape gets passed from here to
here and is life like that I mean it
seems to me like that's the way life
really happens is you know we can go out
and say I'm going to achieve this and I
want but aren't we most likely to be
pleasantly surprised by things that
happen upon us well I think yeah you're
exactly right you know Robert Schuler
says your greatest success will always
be God's greatest SE Secret in other
words the person that helps you will be
the least likely to have intersected in
your life but there's that that great uh
analogy if you will luck really is the
intersection of preparation and
opportunity if opportunities are not out
there if opportunity is within you then
if you're always out there you're liable
to run into somebody who will help you
get what you want but unless you're out
there so I have a UPS driver and he says
I've always wanted to be a rock star Dr
waitley and I said ' where are you
singing now he said ' no I'm delivering
packages and I got this small I said no
you don't understand whatever you want
to become you need to be doing it now
you can't put it on layaway you have to
be practicing within when you're without
you have to be singing Somewhere because
if you look at everyone who's been
successful you'll find that they're
using their free time their prime time
as preparation for what they really want
to do so they don't just wait for
opportunity to show up they're out there
intersecting it every day and that's
where luck comes from yeah was it Armen
Hammer said uh the harder I work the
luckier I get I think that's what he
said and and it really is true and I
think maybe that's some reason why some
people don't ever get to achieve their
dreams is because they they aren't
working on themselves so that when the
door of opportunity does swing open
they're able to walk through it well
that's true and that's why I like this
kind of program so much if you figure
that we spend most of our free time
watching other people making money
having fun in their profession they're
loving what they do the ones that are
doing sitcoms in reality they love it
because they're being paid for what they
love to do and we're watching them and
keeping their ratings up yeah because
we're doing things that overcome the
frustration of the mediocrity in a day
that we really didn't want to spend and
that's why I think you got to live in
prime time you got to watch things that
you want to become and be inspired by
what you watch rather than just
titilated you know rather than just be
shocked or viscerally stim stimulated I
think you have to be emotionally and
mentally stimulated and inspired that's
why I like to watch positive television
because it really helps I watch National
Geographic and Discovery Channel and the
History Channel and I watch programs
that really make me feel better about
myself of course you know what that does
it makes you motivated into realizing
you're not doing as well as you could
and it makes you maybe forced to be a
little stressed and get out of your
comfort zone yeah so you end up doing uh
psychology of winning how many audio
programs did that sell that sold uh 2
million uh 2 million copies at $50 a
piece wow uh first go around and it's
just it's been chugging along uh for 25
years ever since Y what are the keys in
the psychology of winning program if if
somebody said what are the three main
things that I would want to walk away
with that would um enable me to apply
them to my life and change my life what
would they be I think one of the first
things would be that uh you believe in
your potential and you invest in it
because you're as good as the best but
no better than the rest so if you
actually believe that you're valuable
without having done anything then that's
potential and that way you'll put
Education and Training into you so you
have to at least you believe believe
that you're better than what you're
doing then I think the other thing would
be is that who's in charge here and I
always say you know um God deals and
says go ahead make your choice uh do
what you choose but remember there are
rules of the game and I will keep you as
the field judge on track and so what
I've done is try to be accountable and I
tell people that accountability or
personal responsibility that Winners
make it happen and losers let it happen
that winners deserve to win there never
was a winner who wasn't a beginner so
when you begin anything new you're
awkward you don't feel confident so you
need to still keep in mind you hang on
to your dream when that's all you have
to hang on to you feel responsible and
accountable for the outcome and you
focus all your intensity on desired
result instead of penalty of failure you
go through life driving through the
windshield rather than looking through
the rearview mirror if you're always
looking through the rearview mirror
you're going in the opposite direction
and a fear can become as much of a goal
as a goal because a fear is a goal going
in the opposite direction so I think the
feeling of deserving the feeling of
accountability the feeling of having a
focused idea something specific that you
want maybe a Magnificent Obsession and
then be willing to put the practice in
that the rest of the population aren't
willing to do because I think that uh if
you do it right right in drill you'll do
it right in life I learned that as a
pilot I learned that watching and and
helping the
astronauts observation imitation
repetition simulation rehearsal
internalization reflex there never was
an Olympian who didn't practice so much
that when they went to do it they just
remembered yeah they didn't try so I I
think the self- disipline combined with
belief in self would be the key that
persistence and look at failure as the
fertilizer of life you know trying to
remain optimistic through setbacks the
mental toughness of that would be
another key you know you mention
athletes you've worked a lot with
athletes in fact chairman of psychology
for the US Olympic Committee uh Olympic
teams from 1980 to
1992 right and we we look at athletes at
least I do you know you go to a
professional baseball game and you see
this guy walk into the Batters box and
here comes this pitch 90 M an hour it's
curving the next one 70 mph there's so
much to take in and we watch this person
just effortlessly swing and hit this
ball 410 ft over the the fence and there
is a danger I think when we see
successful people whether it's in
athletics or business people or whatever
to think that it came easy to them to
think that oh they're just good at what
they do or they've been lucky or you
know whatever these excuses we make to
make it easy for them but what we don't
see is the thousands of hours of
practice in a batting cage or or writing
speeches and rewriting speeches if
you're a public speaker all these
different things what do you think is
the key to developing our lives so that
we can become successful uh as it
relates to this practice makes perfect
idea I mean it's one thing to say okay I
can see what a professional baseball
player has to do he has to take hundreds
and hundreds of pitches thousands of
hours in a batting cage but how does
that apply when you're a manager in a
company or a a mom raising your kids how
do you how does that concept transfer
over well I think it's just the same uh
behind every worldclass athlete there's
a world class coach behind every world
class person there's a worldclass coach
you find people with proven track
records of success who've been where you
want to go and you learn the correct
swing before you can play the inner game
of anything so you got to learn the
swing with each Club golf is a great
example
most of us go out in the driving range
and hit a bucket of balls and I go out
and practice my hooks my slices my dubs
and my Lofts and I practice my mistakes
because I didn't have a coach role model
or mentor to teach me how to do it right
I've been using trial and error and
unfortunately the errors are the ones
that are practiced and repeated what you
do in each of these instances in my
opinion is to find someone who's doing
what you want to do and doing it well
maybe they're about your age or maybe
they're older but they're usually
someone that you can use as a role model
uh you know you don't use a celebrity
who you'll never meet and somebody who's
you know I wouldn't look at M Michael
Jordan if I were just trying to shoot
better free throws right I would find
somebody that was most like me I'd read
about them I'd study their lives and I
try to go to seminars programs and watch
videos of of them and I I'd rehearsed
the the correct swing because even
Harvey McKay has been saying that in his
books practice doesn't make perfect it
makes permanent only perfect practice
makes perfect so why would you practice
your errors and that's why I tell young
people why do you think that you have to
go out and make all the mistakes
yourself rather than listen to Veterans
so every veteran should have a rookie
and every rookie should have a veteran
because the rookies have the energy
believe they can't fail the veterans
know if you persist you will succeed and
the veterans also have learned the
correct swing so I think one of the
secrets is to study success rather than
failure and not go out and trial and
error I think it's to simulate the real
thing I said uh two things that I think
of when I think of Dennis wayy
psychology of winning seeds of greatness
not many people get to have a great
followup I mean there are lots of people
that do a a great thing very few few
people or even fewer people actually do
a great thing and follow it up with a
great thing how did seeds of greatness
come about well I backed into that
because I was known as as an audio voice
you know kind of Pat Boon warmed over
right you know some people no some
people say to me you know how did you
sell that many tapes you know I mean
you're not that exciting and I said well
thank you very much I'm excited on the
inst they say you're no Tony Robins you
know it's and I said no I'm not I'm I'm
who I am and I don't try to copy other
people but the interesting thing and of
course I like to make fun of myself I
like to be a bob newart with a little
Vince Lombardi shoved on the inside Bob
newart personality on the outside I like
to really poke fun of myself so I don't
get impressed because one of the worst
things you can do is begin to get
impressed with yourself you know but uh
I've said I've sold so many tapes
because America has trouble sleeping and
if you'll pop one of my tapes in at
bedtime I mean it's really a good way to
relax it's more expensive than NY will
they hey same same sort of that's true
but I think having spoken a lot for
companies and remembering my grandmother
I needed a sequel of some kind I didn't
need son of psychology of winning or
psychology winning too so I went back to
my grandmother's idea of the garden and
I began to write another program only
this time it was a book Because I had
not written a best-selling book I mean
psychology of winning as a book was was
not a number one bestseller it was just
a listening program so I wrote seeds of
greatness and likened it to the garden
and remembered what my grandmother said
about the seeds and the success and it
happened to be one of the bestselling
books in in the in the 1980s what are
the key seeds of greatness well the seed
of uh the seed of Love would be to look
for good uh in somebody I think to love
someone is to look for the good in them
and to overlook the blemishes and and to
uh to realize that love is not
conditional so unconditional love means
you accept people in spite of what they
they do I think another seed is the a
seed of U Faith there's no such thing as
a lack of faith there's only good faith
or bad faith because uh it either is
depresses you your negative Faith or it
inspires you and faith is in something
unseen and maybe unknown and yet you
believe it because you believe it with
all your heart but it may not be
something you've experienced firsthand
and and I think the uh the seed of
uh of perception or
perspective uh looking Beyond yourself
for meaning in life looking at the big
picture uh believing that it's unfolding
as it should be and that that I'm I'm
fitting into the harmony of the way it
was created I think perspective is great
being able to see clearly with a A
Vision that of the world and not become
pessimistic and of course the seed of uh
of direction or or goals I mean goals
are like U guided missiles they have a
navigational guidance computer inside
and you set a Target and makes negative
feedback Corrections and hits the target
if you don't have a Target it wanders
aimlessly around or self-destruct so I
think uh some of those seeds were
similar to the psychology of winning but
they they really likened it more to a
garden and at the end you realize the
garden is never complete because just
when you think it's a great life and the
garden is perfect some ants and some
aphids come over here it rains too much
or rains too little and the garden
always needs tending you never will have
a perfect garden and life is like that
too just when it looks so good something
else comes along to make you have to get
back and cultivate and do some more
planting yeah seeds of greatness has a a
special part in my life because the
first time I ever met you and I I'm
assuming you remember this because we've
talked about it a few times uh I was
going to put on conferences I had this
big idea I was going to be a conference
promoter so I had a friend and I called
him up he was putting on a conference
where you were speaking and I said hey
I'd like to come and just learn you know
kind of like you were saying if you want
to do something go learn from people who
are already doing it so uh my son and I
came and he was probably N9 or 10 at the
time something like that and um I called
this friend and I said hey can I come
come and help out to see the inner
workings of putting on a conference and
he said I really need somebody to drive
Dennis Whitley around so if you could be
his Coast while he's here and I thought
hey super so I had my son read seeds of
greatness I think when he was N9 or 10
years old and I was so impressed because
uh he was just a chatter box you know
after reading the book he wanted to know
all the you know the questions and and
uh I was just impressed that you took
the time and that was really my first uh
opportunity to meet you and to to see
that that just like you've said you
can't believe all the Press about
yourself and I've always been amazed at
at what a a Kind and Generous person
you've been and uh in all the different
areas of your life and so that's always
been impressive to me that's got to be
one of the seeds of greatness maybe not
actually written in the book but this
idea of of being a a pursuer of
achievement and those types of things
but remaining humble how does humility
play into this idea of I want to be
successful I want to be achiever an
achiever but at the same time remaining
humble about who we are and a Kind and
Generous type of person well I feel that
if you got the real thing you don't have
to flaunt a loud expensive imitation uh
the people that shout the loudest are
calling for help so there's always this
in-your-face kind of person and that
works for gladiators because Gladiators
need to intimidate people and maybe it
works in the arena but in real life it
doesn't I've always felt that arrogance
is God's gift to shallow people in other
words uh the longer the stretch of the
limousine is that you need to ride in
the more you need to stretch yourself to
hide the lightly valued self of the
little child inside so I think
self-esteem is inversely proportional to
the stretch of the limousine because the
limousine should be ridden in because
you enjoy it not because other people
are impressed by it so I think the
people that try to be impressive are the
least impressive the people that talk
about themselves the most are very
boring because one of the things that's
I've learned is no one cares really
about what you've done unless it
benefits the person who's listening why
show slides of your trip they're not
interested in where you've been unless
you got a ticket waiting for them so I I
try not to say things that are important
to me unless I feel there's some value
for somebody else and I think humility
is serving others with Grace and you
stop to think about some of the greatest
people they've got so much going for
them they're so successful
why wouldn't they be warm and generous
and eager to share it I mean why
wouldn't they give back to the fans what
the fans have given them the financing
and the the the agulation so why
wouldn't you be the most humble gracious
warm open stay for hours and sign help
little kids I mean after all that's what
made you who you are sure and I've
always felt that one of my daughters
came home and she said dad there's this
greatl looking guy he's an athlete and a
student and he can dance and oh he's
what a hunk and he spoke to me I said
come on honey let me tell you something
if he's good-look and an athlete and
smart and can dance and is a hunk he
should be the most warm and because look
what he's got going for him he's got all
this success inside why wouldn't you
pass on your winds and that's what I
feel you unless you pass your WIS on
it's a hollow Victory to stand there
over a fallen adversary to say look at
me I'd rather say we did it you know
share the glory and build other winners
too and I think that really makes a
champion what are some of the greatest
lessons you've learned over life wow
there's there's been plenty yeah uh some
of them I've learned is that uh uh
persistence and Patience are not exactly
the same because persistence can become
obstinance so what you can do is if I
fail once then I need to learn more if I
fail twice I need to learn more if I
fail three times I need to do it a
little differently and if I fail four or
five or six or seven times maybe I have
set my goals a little too high maybe I
need to bring them in a little bit and
I've learned it's much better to succeed
by the
inch rather than to try to go for the
touchdown in one play to stair step
success and pull myself along because
you get reinforcement when you succeed
in a small way and you can overcome your
mistakes easier if if you bite off
little pieces rather than try to take
these big because most people give up
because they say I knew I knew it
wouldn't work right that's because
they're not incrementalization another
thing I've learned is that I I am as
good as the best meaning that I have
potential that I can do but I'm know
better than anyone who's ever been born
or has yet to be born and that's why I
say I'm not impressed I I express but I
don't impress and I've learned that that
works for me and I've learned that some
of the best people people I've ever met
are so humble and I say wow uh you know
we talked about that maybe in coming
over you know we talked about a a star
who's nice right well why wouldn't they
be you know why would they be this
Primadonna BEC they're Primadonna
because it came quick came easy and that
maybe they didn't have to really work
hard to get it because you have to work
hard to get it you never forget who
brought you to the dance so I I try to
remember who said the quote who to give
credit to and make sure I never forget
anyone who's ever helped me uh I think
another thing that I've learned is that
um failure really is the stuff that
success is made of if you use it as
mulch or fertilizer you don't want to
wallow in your mistakes you want to
learn from them so it's a learning
experience and a temporary inconvenience
but failure is not a person it's an
event I learn that every day failure is
an event not a person so don't worry
your failure is on your back you don't
have to carry them forward you learn
from them and somebody told me that the
other day they said you know I'm
divorced and I said you're unmarried or
single when were you divorced they said
I was divorced three years ago and I
said I'm glad it's over so in other
words it's final yeah and now you can go
forward and learn from that and maybe
you know have a better relationship next
time yeah we all make mistakes we all
have failures we all you know all the
people that we see who are successful
you can look back in their life and say
hey there were there were problems there
were bankruptcies there were divorces
there were you know all sorts of of
difficulties and yet isn't it true that
the most successful people are really in
many ways just the people who keep going
they're the ones who decide to keep
going instead of quitting it's really
not rocket science you know they they do
have patience and persistence and they
they hang in there and they keep trying
they don't give up the other thing they
do I think is your selfworth in the long
run influences your net worth so your
net worth is your achievement and your
selfworth gives you a
passport to achievement it allows you to
believe that you can add a zero to your
income and you don't have to uh wait for
an opportunity you know we've talked
about that earlier I will never wait for
an incoming call because I've never had
an incoming call offering me an
opportunity only offering me something
to buy yeah people call me to achieve
their goals I call them to have them
help me achieve mine so I think you
really have to make outgoing calls
rather than wait for the incoming call
to give you that lucky
break you have entered into a new stage
in your life where you're developing uh
a lot of Concepts around a topic that is
new at least to your public life
certainly not to your your personal life
tell us what you're doing now well I
I've decided to be more of a a family
leadership guy because I made so many
mistakes raising my own children you
know I've had his hers ours theirs been
a single father for 9 years and so I
want to plant the seeds of greatness in
the Next Generation and I'd like to see
us pass on values to our kids roots and
wings instead of Loot and things if you
give your kids Loot and things they
won't have any roots and wings because
they'll believe that money grows on a
tree that is given to them bye the Dad
or Mom tree the credit card tree or the
born in America tree or the entitlement
tree and it doesn't grow on that so I'm
really hoping to take a new version of
the seeds of greatness for the next
generation and do some roots of core
values and some wings of of self
motivation and and expectancy and really
try to help because I'm worried you know
I'm always you know maybe when you get
older you worry yeah I believe the
country's in good hands with young
leadership but I think there's a skin
deep culture that's invested in
immediate gratification and I think we
need to delay Gra ification for the goal
rather than try to get everything
now what are the key principles that
you're trying to communicate through
seeds of greatness in your family
leadership program well I think one of
the most important ones has to do with
money believe it or not that uh we don't
talk about money with our kids uh it's
almost as taboo as sex and so if we
talked about how money is earned how
money is spent and let them go down and
go to the grocery store and take the
coupons with us and learn to make
choices based on what something's Worth
to give children an allowance early to
have them learn how to manage money 30%
to spend now 50% to uh spend later in
the year uh 10% to give away to someone
needy or the church and then 10% for the
future which you don't spend and learn
how to use debit cards instead of credit
cards and that you have to pay for your
own cell phone bill and if you're going
to message other students it's going to
cost some money and to have this m
mentality that if I give value then I
receive value but it doesn't just come
because of where I was born or who I am
so that's one of the things would be to
internalize value and then make them
realize there's effort and delay
gratification to get there and I think
the important thing is to develop a
belief in one's potential that isn't
always measured against celebrity or
athletic ability that believe that I'm
worthy of success and then get the
discipline and early
responsibility to make choices and live
with those choices as long as they're
not dangerous in other words a parents
role should be uh to plant the seeds to
let them mistake U make mistakes in a
safe environment as long as that doesn't
damage them physically or emotionally
and let them get the logical consequence
or reward of their efforts and choices
as early as possible so we can really
develop a generation of of shall we say
hungry immigrants in our own country who
are hungry for knowledge and are working
as hard as an immigrant would work
having just come to this country you
think that sometimes we do our kids a a
lack of justice so to speak in
protecting them too much not allowing
them to experience the things that they
need to experience oh I actually do we
tend to give our children everything
they didn't or and everything we didn't
have we want our children to do better
than us so we try to facilitate that
and we really don't want them to fail
and that's a problem because that's a
very com uh healthy thing is to make
mistakes so we tend to protect them
number one but we expect the best
because we want them to live up to our
expectation because it makes us feel
like a good parent if they do well and
the problem with that is that we
probably engage them in way too many
organized activities and we over promote
their time and pretty soon it's all
activity based and they don't don't end
up being able to be a child they don't
have dinner together you know I just
read the other day that uh the parents
that eat with their children have
children who are more successful in
school and in college than those that
don't eat with them a few times a week
so I think turning the television off
during supper eating with the child and
being a Hands-On parent rather than a
parent that just uh tries to buy the
child's affection rather than giving
them time Dennis waitley thanks for
being with us I appreciate you and all
your knowledge and all the things that
you've done and just all the things that
we can learn from you and people like
yourself who who sort of lead the way in
the area of uh thoughts and ideas and
action and goal setting and all that
type of thing so well thank you I really
have to pay a compliment back to you
though you know I've seen your growth
and seen where you've come and you've
come so far and I'm just so excited that
we have a a generation of Champions that
are in this new 21st century and I'm
just excited to be a friend and also a a
commentor with you a collaborator It's
Great To Be With You Chris thanks thanks
y to see Chris's interview with Jim Ron
which was the last time Jim ran did a
video interview check it out right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there what you're about to watch is the
last video interview that Jim ran ever
did he sits down with Chris Weidner to
talk about how to get the right mentors
set meaningful goals and stop being
broke